[Music]
this is not some DVD floating in space
it's a mega structure that might one day
become humanity's home the earth might
not remain habitable forever
it could get engulfed by a massive solar
flare or become too hot due to climate
change or have all its life wiped out by
one enormous asteroid what if I told you
we could outlive all these disasters and
that we could do that by building a
space mega structure bigger than the Sun
itself just how big would we have to
make it and what would life be like on a
structure like that this is what if and
here's what would happen if we could
build an Alderson disk
why would we colonize other currently
uninhabitable planets if we could
hypothetically build a habitat of our
own something that would host many
billions of future humans without ever
running out of space it does look like a
DVD doesn't it
only it has the mass of three thousand
suns the reason why we need our Alderson
discs to have such a huge mass is
gravity all objects with mass are
gravitationally drawn to each other and
objects with a greater mass have a
greater gravitational pull for the
Alderson disc to be stable enough to
host life we've needed to have a
stronger pull than the Sun does that's
where it gets tricky because the Sun is
the most massive object in our solar
system
accounting for ninety-nine point eight
percent of its total mass to have enough
material to outweigh the Sun we'd have
to get it by breaking down every planet
moon and asteroid in a radius of
hundreds of light-years around us or we
could give our Alderson disc artificial
gravity
this type of gravity isn't caused by
attraction but by acceleration or
centrifugal force in other words we'd
have to spin our disk fast enough that
it doesn't collapse into a doughnut or
get swallowed by the Sun
but since we haven't really figured out
artificial gravity yet let's stick with
the first option and make our Alderson
disc very very massive 241 million
kilometers wide that would make it
stretch past the orbit of Mars it would
also be several thousand kilometers or
miles thick and would have a
surface-area
equivalent to over 1 billion Earth's
[Music]
just imagine how many billions of humans
could live on it ah but not so fast
our Alderson disc wouldn't be habitable
everywhere and before I explain that let
me talk about the Sun for a moment our
Sun would be sitting stationary in the
hole at the center of the disk and
because of this our disk would have no
day and night cycle only a never-ending
Twilight but since our disk would have a
bigger mass in a stronger gravitational
pull there's a chance that the Sun would
wobble up and down that would somewhat
solve our day and night problem but it
could also increase the possibility of
colliding with our star
we might need to install gamma-ray
lasers to have more control over the
sun's wobbling and still our disc shaped
world would need way more things to
become suitable for us to live on it one
of the most important things is an
atmosphere on earth the atmosphere
protects us from harmful ultraviolet
radiation it reduces temperature
extremes and it creates pressure that
allows liquid water to exist we'd need
an atmosphere to do all the same things
for our elderson disk and to keep the
Sun from stealing it we'd need to build
a wall around the disks inner edge
unlike earth the Alderson disk wouldn't
have liquid metal in its core to give it
a magnetosphere a magnetic field is
important because it keeps the solar
wind from stripping off the atmosphere
without it the solar wind would erode
the part of the Alderson disc closer to
the Sun this could make the entire
structure unstable and possibly destroy
it altogether once we figure out how to
make the atmosphere and magnetic field
we could bring in water we'd make holes
in the disk that would allow for oceans
because of the way gravity would work on
our Alderson disk the water could be
suspended the oceans on the disk shaped
structure would literally be bottomless
for the same gravitational reasons
humans would be able to live on both the
top and the bottom side of the disk for
those living on the bottom side it
wouldn't feel as if they were walking
upside down it would be just normal on
each side but of course this space
mega-structure could have some flaws
because of the discs enormous mass its
gravity might make it collapse into a
gigantic torus or even worse a black
hole then there are asteroids even
though we used up all the nearby
asteroids to form our Alderson disk in
the first place there's no guarantee new
interstellar space rocks wouldn't come
and bombard our disk world
not just asteroids but rogue planets as
well even the slightest hit could
destabilize the disk and plunge it right
into the Sun speaking of the Sun
remember I said that not all of the
Alderson discs would be habitable that's
because the Sun wouldn't be heating it
evenly the inner side of the disk would
be very hot to withstand the tremendous
heat we'd have to give our disk a heat
shield just like the one we developed
for the Parker Solar Probe the outer
edges of the disk would be freezing cold
but the middle band of the structure
would be just perfect for life although
there would be a lot of unused space the
habitable area would still be 50 million
times larger than the entire surface of
Earth so a giant platter with the
thickness of several thousand kilometers
it might not survive in space luckily I
have another idea in mind but that's a
story for another what if
you